[Music]
it is
seven o'clock good to see you this
morning it may be less than a week until
coronavirus restrictions in england are
relaxed to their
lowest level since the pandemic began
surging cases i mean the prime minister
is stressing it's a change
which must happen cautiously in a moment
we'll be asking the chief secretary to
the treasury steve barkley about the
coherence of that message we'll also
discuss suggestions
that senior government figures are
hindering rather than helping efforts to
stem the racist abuse
leveled against england's black
footballers also on the program
intolerable mps call for the long-term
detainment of people with autism
to be outlawed the chair of the health
and social care committee jeremy hunt
says the practice is a
national shame we'll be speaking to him
at five past
eight but also on the program
you can cure your euros heartbreak by
getting behind another group of british
stars
i'll be taking a look ahead to the tokyo
olympics with the triathlete alistair
brownlee
at quarter to 10. it is tuesday the 13th
of july
confusing and irresponsible as the pm
confirms the end of england's
restrictions but urges caution
there is criticism from doctors and
business owners
that's not freedom the day that's not
what we've been expecting so again it's
a slight change it's another change of
what we've been told
i'm not happy with that
i will never apologize for who i am
marcus rashford speaks out after
suffering racist abuse following his
missed penalty
in the euros final a changing pattern
of the conservative party is attempting
to break down labour's historical
stronghold among minority voters
an emergency like covid called for
climate change to be treated in the same
way as the global pandemic
good morning you will be very glad to
hear that after yesterday's torrential
downpours
summer is set to make a welcome return
much drier today
and things improving really for the rest
of the week
[Music]
morning all the government may be
pushing ahead with the lifting of
measures in england on monday
but this morning it faces accusations of
mixed messaging and
irresponsible decision making as cases
of the delta variant surge
the british medical association says the
end of most
mandatory restrictions will have
potentially devastating consequences
it comes as modeling from the
government's scientific advisors
suggests that deaths could rise to more
than 200 a day by mid-august
in what's been called an exit wave well
from july the 19th
the legal requirement to wear masks in
shops and on public transport will go
although people are strongly encouraged
to wear them in crowded spaces
restrictions on socialising will be
lifted with the rule of six no longer
applying
indoors but the prime minister says
people should still
show caution and restraint
uh what about business uh well they'll
be encouraged to continue
asking customers to check in through the
test and trace app
but it will no longer be a requirement
nightclubs will be able to reopen and
mass events will return
but venues are being urged to use the
nhs covid pass which shows
proof of vaccination a negative test or
natural immunity
one business owner told our reporter
gerald tubb the messaging
is confusing
and as a matter of social responsibility
we're urging nightclubs
this owner of two leeds clubs had been
promised
freedom day on the 19th instead
he heard the prime minister saying he
should check his customers
covet status as a means of entry
that's not what we've been told is that
that's not freedom that day that's not
what we've been expecting so again it's
a slight change it's another change of
what we're being told
i'm not happy with that you know i think
that we need to put the owners back on
people and we need to let people make
their own decisions people
need to take their own responsibilities
it's a view shared by many in the
hospitality industry
across england keen to get their
businesses back into profit and weary of
mixed
messages but the government's newfound
caution
contrasts with a survey of 18 to 30 year
olds
that says more than nine out of ten
intend to head back to late night venues
one in five immediately the evidence
that most young people
intend to quickly return to socializing
in bars and clubs like this as much as
they did before the pandemic
will only add to concerns that we could
be heading for another
big rise in infections
from next week all legal restrictions
are being lifted
masks on buses will no longer be
compulsory
with a forecast from government advisers
that deaths could rise to
200 a day some passengers are wary
i think we should keep them until we
know they're all safe to be fair i think
the people that have always worn them
will wear them and the people who don't
still won't
behavioral experts warn that guidance
and advice
is not always effective if they want
people to wear masks the mandatory
strategy was more advised even if you
say oh
we do advise you to wear them it still
signals
um cove it isn't a big deal anymore your
risk of getting it
are is becoming smaller and that leaves
the clinically vulnerable
like rebecca who has cerebral palsy
worried
and angry i think it's a bad idea
for people like myself because
if we do it all wear them then it's not
going to work
and they don't protect it as as well
i think it's a stupid idea to get
up on the 19th of july you feel it would
put
you at risk yeah july the 19th
was billed as the end of restrictions
now it's been
recast as the start of a new chapter in
the pandemic
with cases rising and uncertainty
remaining
sky news leads
uh pleased to say joining us in the
studio of the chief secretary to the
treasury stephen barclay mr buckley
really good to see you this morning
um i wonder if i can start with a quite
a broad question
do you accept as as those we interviewed
in gerard's report have pointed out that
there have been
once again mixed messages but this time
around june
july the 19th i mean is it a return to
normality or not
it's about getting the balance right so
we've been clear we delayed for
four weeks uh the step four which has
enabled us to strengthen that vaccine
wall an additional seven
million vaccines have been delivered in
that time
but there's no perfect time to start
reopening and that's what the prime
minister the chief medical officer
chief scientific advisor were clear on
yesterday
so what we're doing is we're reopening
with the summer holidays with the summer
weather
that is seen as the best time to do so
we are going to have to live
with the virus and return to normal
but at the same time be cautious and
that's the balance that the prime
minister was striking yesterday
but according to the government's own
scientists the consequence
of opening up on july the 19th is and
there
and estimates vary but perhaps as high
as 200 deaths a day
i mean is that an acceptable price for
reopening well what they also said is
there is no perfect time
and actually reopening when the schools
are back in september reopening when
the colder weather is also bringing
other challenges
also brings its risk so there's no
perfect time to do this
what we've done is deploy the vaccine an
extra seven million
opening when the schools are going to be
shut is seen as the optimum time
to do so but it's about getting that
balance right so people
reaching their own judgments being
sensible following the guidance
but we also need to get back to normal
businesses need to to fire up we need to
get the economy going
and those are important as well because
there are consequences to not doing that
both economically and in terms of
people's health of course there are of
course there are but but again
to return to the original question in
terms of mixed messaging
we have been told a variety of things
that now seem rather shaky for example
the idea
that this pathway out of lockdown is is
irreversible
and boris johnson said back in downing
street and tail end of february we will
not go back
we are now traveling on a one-way road
to freedom i mean that that's wrong
isn't it that's just simply not correct
we could see restrictions being
reapplied later on in the year
well i think the the message has been
very clear throughout which is the
vaccine is the key people need to get
their jobs
people have responsibilities let's clear
this up is it reverse
is it reversible or not well we have
taken the culture so the prime minister
addressed this at the press conference
yesterday we're being cautious
in order uh to seek for it to be
irreversible but one never knows
uh you know what he did back in february
when he said we will not go back we are
now traveling on a one-way road
the vaccine has provided that wall an
extra 7 million
vaccines have been delivered as a result
of the extra four weeks
and that's why we've taken that extra
time but we need to learn to live
with the virus we need to get those
businesses open some business has been
closed
for 16 months so it's right we get the
economy moving in that way
and learn to live with the virus but the
key throughout and our message has been
consistent
that the vaccine is key your viewers
have responded to that that's why so
many people
perhaps the one thing the government has
been consistent on that the vaccine is
key to all of this let's talk about
vaccine passports again
nadim zahawi back in february we're not
planning to have a passport in the uk
michael gove on this program will i need
one to go to large sporting events no
passports that's not being planned and
yesterday we again hear from the prime
minister backtracking
that these businesses you know perhaps
which will have large crowds within them
should be using them
as a matter of social responsibility
well i mean if you're saying is this
unprecedented
is this complex is this challenging has
the government
have our scientists been learning about
the virus as we went through we saw that
before christmas
when the kent variant came along we had
to change our plans of course we've
followed the data
and we've changed our plans if the data
has required that
we've followed the science throughout
but it's been complex it's been
unprecedented i think your viewers
appreciate that but they also recognize
that the vaccine is the way through this
we have deployed that two-thirds of the
adult population now having their two
jobs
so the vaccine is the way forward but we
also need to live with
this condition and and get the economy
moving again sure
i will note however in the space of
about a week and a half the emphasis
being placed in all of this by the
government has changed entirely from you
know
ministers referring to it as freedom day
on this program
it's now softly softly be as cautious as
we can i mean just in terms of masks
and we had robert generic on the fourth
of july saying people need to take
personal responsibility
you had to your boss at the treasury
saying that he was going to stop wearing
them as soon as the requirement was
was dropped now we're being told that
being wearing masks
is to be encouraged in some settings i
mean where does the consistency
i i think people are grown up they
understand that many people are
frustrated
with wearing masks it's not particularly
pleasant experience if for example
you're on a long
train journey and if the carriage is
empty then people quite rightly then say
well
is it necessary and that's what step
four and the vaccine
enables us to get rid of but at the same
time if you're on a very busy
commuter tube for example if you're with
people you don't frequently meet
what the guidance is saying is then it's
prudent to wear a mask but what we've
changed is the legal
requirement so we're saying it's no
longer the law to do so
but let's trust your viewers to reach
their judgment when it's crowded when
it's busy
of course we're a matter of two days ago
judgment
two days after july the 19th there will
be a session of prime minister's
questions in which social distancing
requirements in the chamber will be
removed you will be cheated by jail with
your colleagues
there is no mandatory requirement for
people to wear face masks in the chamber
and one must suspect given what we've
heard from
colleagues within your party that some
people will not be wearing them
i mean two days after the country is
told you know let's
stagger returning to work let's wear
masks when you're in crowded places
we're going to see politicians doing the
entire opposite
again i think it's right that parliament
the national pilot comes back together
we
we get that working as it should it
enables the government to be scrutinized
effectively it's for the speaker not for
members of the government to decide what
the rules are
that apply uh in the chamber but what
the guidance has said and what the chief
medical officer was very clear in the
press conference yesterday
is that people will form their judgments
in terms of when it's crowded
as to what is appropriate and i think
your viewers will get that we're
trusting british people
rather than making it a legal
requirement
at the weekend there was no social
distancing no one was wearing any masks
those are the people that you're asking
to show some personal responsibility
those are the people you're asking to
show some common sense you know if we've
got england fans sticking flares up
their backside
it does seem a bit of a it does seem a
bit of a stretch to say that they're
going to be taking the personal
inspections
i think when we're sharing exceptional
cases like that individual i don't think
is where
the british public are in terms of
stress
well i think there were some people
hugely regrettably and the wembley
authorities were reviewing
those who broke into the stadium but
again i think we're talking about a very
small number
of people in a particular circumstance
that is not the norm of the british
people
and the british people i think will
understand the distinction between the
legal requirement to wear mass
which has been the position up to this
point and as we learn to live with this
virus
as we move to step four as we benefit
from the british public responding
in the way they have to taking up the
vaccine that allows us to free up
uh the legal requirement and have
guidance and people will form their
judgment if they're meeting people who
are not from their usual family group
their friendship group
they're meeting people in a very crowded
place they will have the option then
to wear a mask and that is what the
guiders will recommend but but as the
racism
directed at the players you know on the
pitch inside wembley demonstrates the
actions of a small minority
can have a huge impact i just want to
focus a little bit on the racism
that the footballers have have
experienced tyron wings
wrote this on twitter last night you
don't get to stoke the fire
at the beginning of the tournament by
labeling our anti-racism messages
gesture politics
and then pretend to be disgusted when
the very thing we're campaigning against
happens that's an england footballer a
black england footballer
laying some of the blame for the racism
that he and his colleagues experienced
at the door of your party at the door of
your home secretary well i
completely condemn the racism that those
footballers have suffered i think
the country at large does and has been
shocked by it and that's why the
government
is taking action through the online
homes bill the culture secretary
as you know has been meeting with senior
black footballers
uh working with them to ensure that the
the companies that provide the platforms
for this racist abuse are tackled we're
bringing legislation
forward to do that what has been taken
against natalie elfic
your colleague within the party who sent
a message to the conservatives whatapp
group
they lost would it be ungenerous to
suggest rashford should have spent more
time
perfecting his game and less time
playing politics i mean what does it say
about the state of your party
that she felt comfortable sending that
message to her colleagues well that
message was wrong and natalie has
apologized
for it but we're taking action to tackle
at this
through the online homes bill and
that is what needs to happen we need to
ensure that those platforms
take action and if they don't the
government will take action against them
i have often quoted the prime minister
to government ministers on occasions
such as this his comments about
picking innies with watermelon smiles
the problem with africa is that we're
not in charge anymore
his comments about muslim women looking
about like letterboxes and the response
is always
that they need to be viewed in context
but isn't the context that those remarks
now need to be seen in
is that the dog's abuse that has been
thrown against black
english footballers simply because they
missed a penalty kick
isn't that the context in which we need
to view those remarks now no we need to
condemn those remarks
uh against the footballers the the the
racism that they've suffered is
completely
unacceptable that is why we have taken
action
in terms of the online's farm bill and
that is why the platforms
that provide the opportunity for people
to make those remarks
themselves need to take urgent action
we've been very clear on that the
culture secretary has been working
with the fa uh with leading footballers
to ensure action is taken is completely
unacceptable and we are acting on it why
on earth would the prime minister and
the home secretary
choose not to condemn fans who were
booing players who took the knee it's a
gesture that they have made perfectly
clear
from the start of the tournament it's
not about black lives matter but it was
about them
making a stand against racism racism
that we've just seen clearly demonstrate
in the past 48 hours well the home
secretary has repeatedly taken
a stand against races which she herself
has been subjected
to with respect the home secretary
herself has been the subject
of appalling online racist abuse
she herself has been on the receiving
end of this
she has consistently condemned racist
abuse
online and she is taking action as home
secretary
against some of the extreme right-wing
groups that are responsible
for this so she is using her office to
take action to clamp down on it but she
herself has suffered from it she
understands it and she is acting on it
stephen barkley good to see you this
morning and as i said in the studio as
well great to have you on thanks for
being with us
uh now still to come on the program at
half past seven
uh i'll be asking the maid of greater
manchester andy burnham what he makes of
moves to ease
lockdown measures in england next monday
at quarter to eight we'll be discussing
calls for climate change to be regarded
as an emergency
like the coronavirus pandemic
a tale of two cultures we're going to be
joined by the writer
florenceology day to discuss her new
memoir about being born
about being british born but raised in
africa at that coming your way
and quarter tonight
but as we always do time to take a quick
look at the latest coronavirus
data 34 471
new infections were reported in the most
recent 24-hour period along with six
deaths it takes the total number of
people who died within 28 days of a
positive test
to 128 431.
42 000 first doses of coronavirus
vaccines have been
given 107 620 received their second that
means
34.87 million people have now been fully
vaccinated
against the crisis
our economics and data editor ed conway
has been taking a look at the direction
in which some of the numbers are moving
a lot of new numbers there from the
prime minister and indeed his colleagues
and it's worth just
taking it apart and looking at what the
data is saying about covert 19.
right now the broad story is that cases
are going up
a fair bit but you're seeing a bit of a
divergence between cases and emissions
and the best way of looking at that
is looking at these charts these lines
showing you the dark blue one is
cases the higher there is the more cases
and the red line is showing you hospital
admissions it's on a different axis here
but i've put them together so you can
get a sense of look how similar those
shapes are there and look at the lines
starting to diverge
more recently but you don't get a sense
there from that about what's happening
with growth rates for that we need to
look at a logarithmic chart so same data
logarithmic scale on both sides and what
you can see is the steeper these lines
are the faster
the growth rate and have a look over
here there is a divergence isn't there
there's a gap between these two lines
but the steepness of those lines
is actually quite similar in fact
they're both doubling every 11 days so
cases doubling every 11 days admissions
doubling every 11 days and if you carry
that on
here's what you might see in the future
simple extrapolation based on recent
growth rates
you're talking about cases getting up to
about 100 000 by late july so that's not
a modeling
that's you know although sages saying
something similar that's just based on
recent growth rates and that's been a
pretty reliable
indicator of where we've had it recently
same thing for hospitalizations if you
had that
have that going up by the same rate
you're talking about over a thousand
uh by the middle of july as well and
potentially getting up to 2000
uh as well but notably that is a lot
lower
uh than we saw in those previous winter
peaks so i just put that back to
the kind of chart we saw before so not
logarithmic and look at the kind of
height of those so you've got cases
going a lot higher
than they were in the in the winter
whereas you've got hospitalizations
a fair bit low but still there will be
concerns about what that means
uh for the nhs another way of just
looking at this is looking at what
happens
to hospitalizations and just comparing
the shape of these lines
last time around so the dark line is
last time around the winter spike
in hospitalizations and this time around
is that red line you can see already
we're running at a lower rate in terms
of the increase in hospitalizations
and the same thing again for intensive
care emissions going up pretty steeply
in the winter but less steeply this time
around so that might
reassure those in government looking at
this but nonetheless
the numbers especially on cases are
likely to get quite
scary in the next few weeks
ed conway there uh some other news now
and heavy rain caused
flash flooding in parts of london and
the south of england last night
in israel worth in west london cars
could be seen driving through
flooded roads a number of underground
stations were closed
uh all this is the met office issued a
weather warning for a large part
of southern england
uh well this was the scene on portobello
road in west london
after nearly three inches of rain hit
the capital in just
90 minutes it's a bit deeper than three
inches doesn't it residents in nearby
ladbroke grove were left counting the
cost of the damage
with the council saying some homes were
evacuated due to flooding
and collapsed ceilings
police in cuba are patrolling the
capital havana following protests
against food shortages
and high prices the country is
experiencing its worst economic crisis
in decades during the covert 19 pandemic
following the tightening of decades-old
sanctions under the former u.s president
donald trump
uh cuban president miguel diaz-canel has
said the demonstrations were being
stirred up on social media
at least 50 people have died at a
hospital in southern iraq after a
fire tore through the covered 19 ward
the country's health ministry has not
provided an official account as to what
caused the blaze
which has left dozens of others injured
a heatwave is raging in the western
united states with firefighters
struggling to contain wildfires across
the country's west coast
last month north america saw its hottest
june ever
and california and oregon are set to
fuel near record temperatures
in the coming days our u.s correspondent
greg milam has the latest
from palm springs in california
well they're no strangers to the heat
here in palm springs but even in this
desert city the last few weeks and
particularly the last few days have been
pretty intense here day after day of
record-breaking temperatures and we now
know
that they just had the hottest dune ever
here in palm springs you can see what
they tried to do to
help people who are here these misters
that catch the passers-by
something of a lifesaver on a a day like
today but you can see for yourself the
restaurants
certainly outside empty at the moment
and it's not just here in palm springs
of course
large sways of the western united states
seeing this heat tens of millions of
people
in places not used to dealing with it
are now being affected by it and the
climate scientists say we can expect to
see more of this in the years to come
the effects of climate change making
these heat waves more likely
and more intense and particular problem
here is that the minimum temperature
every day is also setting records so
it's not even cooling down at night
to allow people to recover from the heat
of the day and the doctors say that is a
a stressor on the human body this is one
factor the heat there is extreme drought
across huge parts of this part of the
united states
we've seen those wildfires as a result
of those tinder dry
uh conditions the the wildfires here in
california
have burned more twice as much in fact
of the state
as they had at the same stage last year
and last year was a record-breaking year
for wildfires in california there are
power lines in those wildfire areas that
are also at risk putting power supplies
uh in real danger one firefighter here
is saying it looks like
we're about to have a whole year of
summer
uh let's see how the weather is looking
domestically kirsty's standing by with
all the details and if the papers are to
be believed kirsty you can clarify this
one we might have a heat wave of our own
on the way
um we could do and certainly it won't be
anything like the scene
in parts of america and also in
scandinavia are
really really hot at the moment but we
are expecting to see a return of
summer to earth shores and i think for
many that will be a welcome change
especially
after yesterday's rain
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning not everybody likes the
heat but i think most of us would be
glad to see something a little bit more
summery return to our shores
looks as though the next few days will
be fairly settled warming up quite
nicely into the weekend
a little bit gray in places this morning
but the cloud will thin and break and
there are a few showers lingering from
last night but
nothing like those showers yesterday
we're not going to see those again today
thankfully so for many it's a largely
dry day with brighter sunny spells
light well scattered showers so a good
chance you'll stay dry
northern and eastern coast a little bit
cloudier with them some low cloud and
coastal fog here but temperatures widely
into the low 20s
any showers that develop will fade away
this evening to leave a dry night
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now the last time this happened was four
centuries ago the national trust says
a baby beaver has been born on x-men oh
there we go eczema for the first time in
400 years
here is the kit as of course they're
known caught on film at the holland
court estate in somerset
it comes after the trust reintroduced
two
adult beavers to an enclosure in january
last year
can't believe i got through that one
anyway still to come i'll be chatting
with the mayor of greater manchester
andy burnham
after his take on plans to press ahead
with lifting lockdown in england
[Music]
welcome back the government may be
pushing ahead with the lifting of
measures in england on monday
but it is urging people to show caution
as coronavirus cases rise
in the last few minutes i spoke to the
chief secretary to the treasury stephen
barkley
here's what he had to say to accusations
that the messaging is confusing
if you're saying is this unprecedented
is this complex is this challenging
has the government have our scientists
been learning about the virus as we went
through we saw that before christmas
uh when the kent variant came along we
had to change our plans of course we
followed the data
and we've changed our plans if the data
has required that
we've followed the science throughout
but it's been complex it's been
unprecedented i think your viewers
appreciate that but they also recognize
that the vaccine is the way through this
we have deployed that two-thirds of the
adult population now having their two
jobs
um so the vaccine is the way forward but
we also need to live with
this condition and and get the economy
moving again
our political correspondent kate mccann
is in the studio this morning good to
see you um
just just in terms of this accusation of
mixed messaging look it's clearly
not just journalists that are putting
this point to the prime minister but the
journalists that do include
the front page of the daily telegraph
today which is saying something
yeah and i don't really think that steve
barkley could answer the question fully
there because it's a difficult one to
answer i mean
nobody would disagree with him on the
essential point that at some point
we do need to learn to live with covert
19 and we also need to reopen the
economy everybody knows that that's
generally accepted
i think the problem the government has
is that they've gone back and forth on
this idea about is it freedom day
no it's not freedom day you know the
prime minister saying everything's going
to be released and then a week later
saying actually no there'll be pretty
strict guidance actually saying that you
should wear a mask in certain instances
and the point that you put to him you
know you're asking people to use their
common sense which is all well and good
but people want to know what the science
says they want to understand the data
and on that real specific point that you
asked about
you know what's the level of cases that
where we would start to be worried when
would we see the reintroduction of some
stricter measures
there's no answer on that and i think
that will become the problem for the
government because until they can set
that out very clearly
people will be a bit lost and there will
be mixed messaging in terms of
well if you're saying it's not a legal
requirement for you to wear a mask then
it can't be that bad
i probably won't catch the virus because
if i would then you would have told me
to wear one and i think people will
start to make those judgments and we all
have different attitudes to risk
and that will result in people changing
their behavior and i think
that's the thing the government's
worried about and that's why you're
hearing we're listening to the
scientists and we'll change
our policy dependent on the signs which
could see the reintroduction of some
measures later in the year
okay many thanks indeed we're joining us
now to discuss that and much more the
mayor of greater manchester
andy burnham is with us uh good to see
you this morning mr burnham um
good morning let's just start with that
that that central point that we put to
the chief secretary to the treasury this
morning
do you see the messaging as mixed on the
july 19th changes
i'm afraid i do um i think there was a
sensible shift in tone yesterday from
the prime minister and other government
ministers
but all that said to me was they kind of
recognized the problem that they'd
created with all of this rhetoric
about freedom day so there was a
definite step back
but was it enough of a step back to fix
the problem
well well no absolutely not because
you need to put yourself in the shoes
neil of the 3.8 million people in this
country
who are clinically extremely vulnerable
so that's people with
cancer or people who have you know an
immune
condition um is expect and recommend
enough to give them confidence to go out
and get on public transport
next week particularly those who have no
choice but to use public transport and i
would say it's
not enough so i would fully expect come
monday tuesday to be getting complaints
from people that they feel
unable to go to essential hospital
appointments or to be able to get there
get their shopping and this is the point
the government has to take on board
one person's freedom day is another
person's
fear day to what extent then if at all
do you have the capacity as made of
greater manchester to do things
differently you mentioned public
transport there
can you act unilaterally to insist on it
see transport outside of london is
different we only
control part of it and it's not the main
part of it's the tram
system so many more people take bus
journeys every day in greater manchester
and because of the way buses were
deregulated many years ago we don't
control the bus system we don't control
the train system
so if we were to try and enforce on the
trams i think it would cause more
confusion potentially
and it would just be unworkable from an
enforcement point of view
it would be sub-optimal that the right
fix is for the government to recognize
that a mandatory requirement on face
coverings on public transport
is the right way to go because it isn't
purely an issue of personal
responsibility as the government
are saying it is it's exactly like the
passive smoking debate of 15 years ago
one person's choice can affect another
person's physical
and mental health so if you are a cancer
patient going for chemo and you're on a
bus or a tram next week and you're next
to somebody
not wearing a mask that person's
physical health could be at risk but
also their mental health will be
affected
by that situation because of the panic
and the anxiety caused by it so
they just haven't thought this one
through i'm afraid and that
they got themselves into a mess with the
freedom day rhetoric it can't all be
about
individual choices at this stage it's
still a matter of
collective safety everybody acting to
protect each other
to get us through this pandemic i i
wonder if we might talk just a little
bit about the the england game and of
course uh the mural of marcus rashford
um being defeated being defaced in in
whittington i'm just wondering
what action you your office what action
uh
greater manchester police will be taking
uh to establish who is responsible and
and what will happen in future greater
manchester police
reacted very swiftly in the early hours
of
of monday morning uh to cover the
graffiti up and
it will actually be the mural will be
repaired this morning
uh neil which uh is exactly what should
be happening but the people of
manchester have
spoken the people of whittington and
beyond i don't know if you've seen
the mural as it appears right now it is
covered in
unbelievable tributes to marcus role
model
hero which is all exactly what what
he is and while i was you know yesterday
i was so depressed by what had happened
but actually let's not let that one
percent or even less than one percent of
people dominate the news headlines
99 of people have come right behind this
england team
because this is an england team for
everybody and that should be the sort of
abiding memory of this summer they took
us to our first
final in 55 years
and marcus was a part of that how about
we celebrate their achievement
and how about we capture the spirit that
gareth southgate has created around this
england team
and carry it forward and define england
by that not by constantly talking about
these uh this
you know despicable uh one percent of
people who've always kind of brought her
but brought racism to english football
yeah
well another uh england player tyrone
ming's has in essence in a tweet last
night
laid some of the blame for the racism
that he and his colleagues have
experienced that
at the door of senior politicians within
this government he named
pulled out pretty patel uh as an
individual as someone who
he claims was stoking the fanning the
flames of racism
in this country i mean do you agree with
that
well i have to say you know we've lived
through a decade
where leaders have not led when it's
come to protecting everybody's
safety that there has been a you know
dog whistle politics some people call it
i think going from here everyone has to
understand that if somebody in a
position of responsibility fails to
condemn or even
supports a decision uh to attack an
anti-racist
um statement it it it can enable or it
can encourage people beneath to to act
in a
in a racist manner so i i just think
people need to listen to what this these
england players are saying they have
shown
real leadership this summer they came
under huge pressure
to stop uh taking the knee pressure from
many politicians and they did not buckle
and that was leadership to my mind they
stood by their principles
black and white teammates together they
stood as a group a group of working
class
lads who would not be divided and i
think it's a really important message
from that england team to all
politicians all politicians in this
country
including the home secretary i think the
deputy leader of the load party put it
very well yesterday you know if you blow
dog whistles
the dogs will start barking at some
point and you have a responsibility for
that
and i think everyone's going to move
beyond these culture wars and
the kind of pointless divisions that it
creates well not just pointless the
dangerous divisions that they create
and learn from what this england team
has done to this country this this
summer and politicians should be
kind of following that rather than
obviously seeking to derail him
andy burnham thanks very much for
joining us this morning thank you very
much
well the labour party has long reliant
on overwhelming support from black and
asian britons
but at the last election the
conservatives increased their share of
votes from
minority ethnic communities with some
blaming labor
for failing to promote minority talent
within the party
our editor-at-large adam bolton has been
looking at labour's stronghold
among minority ethnic voters and the
conservative
efforts to break it down
for many years an enduring thread in the
tapestry of british politics has been
the assumption
that the labour party had the so-called
ethnic votes stitched up
immigrant families from the indian
subcontinent the caribbean and africa
would vote left on block but times are
changing
perhaps one in four are voting now for
other parties
and there are prominent minority
conservative cabinet ministers
and advisers i think that the labour
party have assumed that the ethnic
minority vote has always been theirs to
have and i think that's why it's come as
a shock in the last few years to see
that
people in areas like mine in sandwell
are starting to change how they
they vote and if there are no efforts to
try and address this then
i think general elections and years to
come could become very unpredictable
was it difficult coming out as a tory um
there was no option if i joked about
voting conservative i
was looked upon possibly even worse than
if i said i wanted to
you know be a drug dealer or a robber
bank
the public image of the conservative
party has certainly changed
20 years ago the tories had no ethnic
minority mps
today they're 22 and a record number of
cabinet ministers
but are ethnic minority voters really
switching to the conservatives
or are the political leaders of the
party ahead of them
professor maria sobolesca studies voter
trends
she believes labor has taken minority
support for granted
they have failed to promote their ethnic
minority politicians
to high office and they have had those
ethnic minority politicians available
uh in the back benches since the 1980s
and they don't really
campaign in areas where ethnic minority
voters live
directly in some in some of these these
areas so
yes labour definitely has a lot of fault
to bear here
back in 1987 diane abbott became
britain's first
black female mp she's still in
parliament
and convinced her choice was the right
one
and why did you want to become an mp
oh i wanted to change the world
and you know if you were black in the
80s the labour party was a part you
joined if you wanted to change the world
and i've not regretted it now on the
back benches she accepts her party
hasn't matched the tories with cabinet
appointments
but she predicts any switchers are in
for disappointments
the tories are not really going to do
anything
for black and brown voters on maths
so i think that the black and brown vote
for the tourists
um has a natural point
beyond which it doesn't go how you're
going to vote for people
that all the time are rolling up
policies which are directed against you
as the government sets out to level up
across the country
no party should take minority votes for
granted
adam bolton sky news
very cosy uh still to come this hour
should climate change be treated with as
much urgency
as the coronavirus pandemic will be
asking two climate experts next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there is a lot of gas being fired all
around us
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's decisive victory
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out
is to get people by boat
what is fear that over 200 people might
have died
because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today
it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
i'm coming from a family of fishermen
actually my family have been fishermen
for five generations
[Music]
the fishermen cut displaced by accident
so we give them the motivation
and the system to bring back to the land
we have collected already more than 110
000 kilos of plastic from the bottom of
the sea
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
after yesterday's downpours the weather
is finally settling down
most places are looking dry today with
sunny spells
a few showers are possible for parts of
scotland england
and wales but these will be lighter and
few and far between compared to recent
days
temperatures up a notch high teens up to
around 23 or
24. a little bit cloudier for some north
sea
coastal areas grass pollen levels will
be high to
very high during the warm sunny weather
spores and wheat pollen levels
also high the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
a report is calling for climate change
to be treated with as much urgency
as the coronavirus pandemic research led
by glasgow caledonian university
says that resources directed towards
combating the virus
would attract focus from countries in
need of environmental aid
pleased to say joining us on the
programme the director at the gcu center
for climate justice professor tazian
jeffrey
and the executive director of the pan
african climate justice alliance
dr mithika mwanda at both joining us on
the programme great to see you both and
and dr moenda to you in just a second um
but professor jeffrey
if we can start with you just establish
exactly the rationale
for treating climate change and coveted
19 in
in similar ways the the rationale is is
quite
simple and straightforward our study has
found
that covert 19 has derailed
the ndc development processes across
africa we have found that resources have
been diverted away from tackling climate
action
uh while being diverted into tackling
uh the pandemic and at the same time we
have seen that the lives and livelihoods
of the
poorest people in the world have
deteriorated and for the first time
extreme poverty is expected to rise
since
1998 so the rationale for tackling
climate action could not be clearer
dr mcwedner tell us then a little bit
about these ndc's these nationally
determined contributions
under paris and why they seem to have
been somewhat displaced over the past 12
to 16 months
well um yeah um since you know
these were investment
instruments which you are agreeing by a
community of nations
uh when they agreed on the the perry
agreement
and each country has committed to what
they are going to do to reduce their
greenhouse gas emissions
and build resilience of communities at
the frontline of climate crisis
over the six the last 12 or six months
we expect 10 countries to deliver on
their second commitment
to to to tell the world under their
commitment
what have they done but because of this
the the the the damage it's
very few countries were able to deliver
on this
and we have seen the breakdown of
climate crisis
uh the the the the climate is uh
actually
the earth is uh is warming if you can
look at what's happening in
various parts of the world and so we are
actually at the tipping point
yet we are not able to be able to
deliver on
what the country is committed to do
under the career agreement
um all of that then professor demands
the question
what is the role for the industrialized
west and
in trying to get this back on track
there's no doubt in our minds that the
industrialized nation need to do
everything they can to to to mitigate
and bring down carbon emissions as fast
as possible
mitigation is only part of the solution
though we need to
put more energy into adaptation and
helping support the poorest nations
to adapt to and cope with the challenges
that climate
crisis is having and compounding the
lives of the poorest
people particularly women and girls in
in these nation states so we are calling
for
uh more support we're calling for more
finance to support the the poorest and
the most vulnerable people
noting that they've contributed little
if anything to
the climate crisis and and and secondly
we
we're calling for um climate action and
for
for the emergency to be seen be tackled
in a more holistic way
bringing together the environmental
health and development sectors
um together um
bringing bringing around the table a
diverse range of stakeholders
um and bringing in people's voices
communities voices to help shape
and develop the solutions to our
crime um uh challenges ahead
uh dr moudner i suspect that those in
in whitehall who point to the cop 26
meeting taking place a little later
uh this year as as evidence of the
industrialized west commitment to
sorting out
uh climate change but at the same time i
i wonder whether you feel that that
africa is
represented as fully as it might be at
summits like cot 26
well uh this actually the the these are
the questions which are
asking um you know the the
in we have been fighting as uh africa
and industrialized countries to see how
we are going to be represented you know
there is the issue of
virtual corpse and also fiscal costs
we are vehemently opposed to virtual
cops because
of the situation in the continent where
energy we require energy
for power at this uh the technologies
the the virtual meetings many people
do not have access to energy precisely
around 600 million africans do not
access that
we need guardians like like these
computers and
we need also internet access
all these do not really
are not affordable and so we find
ourselves disadvantaged
we are pushing and we have what
assurance of the
the cop presidency the uk that
they are working on a physical call and
even if it is physical we find ourselves
again disadvantaged because of the right
now we have
the problem of the vaccine we don't know
whether
many countries have been knocked out
they are not able to access the vaccine
these are the issues of equity and you
find that
africa is generally wherever a crisis
like this not only climate crisis but
also the covenant 19 pandemic and
everywhere that we are going to produce
advantage in terms of
participation and that's what we are
calling is the issue of procedural
justice
but we find ourselves disadvantaged
every time
we have these international processes
like international dialogue on climate
change
climate crisis um i'm afraid both we
will have to leave it there uh dr
moedner
professor jeffrey great to have you on
the programme this morning thanks for
joining us
thank you thank you thank you and just a
reminder you can watch
plenty more stories like that about the
impact on our environment on our daily
climate show that's on
sky news every weekday at half past six
and half past nine
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning parts of the uk saw a
month's worth of rain falling in just a
few hours yesterday but thankfully the
torrential downpours have moved off
although
it is looking very unsettled across
western and central parts of europe in
the coming days
but we should see summer returning i
think welcome news for many of us
so for many it should be a largely dry
start any overnight showers
clearing away it will brighten up as
well so a bit more sunshine coming as
the day goes on
although always staying a little bit
grain misty around some of those north
sea coasts now we might just see a
shower this afternoon across parts of
britain but i really think these will be
few
and far between and certainly lighter
than yesterday's downpours
temperatures reaching into the low 20s
looking largely dry
in the sunshine across parts of northern
ireland and the republic
showers fade away this evening a dry and
mild night will follow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways